BUT FIRST, SEE NANCY FADE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AFTER DEMOCRATS RECAPTURE THE
HOUSE MAJORITY IN 2018,
NANCY PELOSI BECAME THE MOST
POWERFUL WOMAN IN WASHINGTON.
SOME SAID THAT SHE WAS TOO OLD,
THE PARTY NEEDED TO TRADE UP FOR
A NEWER MODEL.
BUT SHE SURE SHOWED THEM.
AT 79 YEARS OF AGE, SHE REMAINS
THE ONLY WOMAN TO EVER HOLD THE
POSITION OF SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, LET ALONE HOLD IT TWO
SEPARATE TIMES.
>> Sean: A
>> Sean: >>
SHE IS THE GLUE KEEPING THE
WHOLE WASHINGTON SCENE TOGETHER.
>> Laura: THAT WAS A FEW
MONTHS BACK.
THAT STILL HOLDS.
A YEAR AGO SHE SEEMED
UNSTOPPABLE.
IN THE GRAND
A GROUP OF NEW FEMALE LAWMAKERS
WHO ARE MAD AS HELL AND NOT
GOING TO TAKE IT ANYMORE.
>> THEY FED UP WITH IT, THEN
THEY BECAME
THEY FIGHT CRIME, THEY WEAR
WHITE BUT THEY ARE NOT ALL
WHITE.
WE LOVE THEM.
THE WOMEN OF CONGRESS!
FEATURING MAXIMUM CLAP BACK
NANCY PELOSI.
>> Laura: SHE'S SO AWOKE, SHE
CAN CLOSE HER EYES?
I HAD TO HAVE WATER FOR THAT.
ALL WEEK LONG, SHE'S BEEN A
WOMAN ON A VERY DIFFICULT
MISSION.
RESIST TRUMP WITHOUT APPEARING
TO BE UNREASONABLE.
CAN RESIST THE RADICALS IN HER
OWN PARTY WITHOUT ALIENATING
THEM AT THE BALLOT BOX.
IF YOU WENT TOO FAR EITHER WAY,
SHE COULD BLOW HER PARTY'S
CHANCES FOR 2020.
AND TIME AFTER TIME ON ISSUES
BIG AND SMALL, THE BELTWAY PRESS
AND KEY DEMOCRATS PRAISE HER
FINESSE, HER POWER, AND HER
STYLE.
AND EVEN HER BODY LANGUAGE.
>> RIDICULOUS PARTISAN
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE HAVE JUST HEARD THAT MEXICAN
CITIES' COOPERATION COMPROMISED
THE COMMON GOOD.
>> Laura: AND ON THE INFAMOUS
CLAP BACK?
LOOK AT THAT.
>> THAT'S THE WAY YOU CLAP WHEN
YOU ARE A HUSBAND PUTS THE
TOILET PAPER ON THE ROLLER.
YOU LEARN!
LOOK AT YOU.
>> Laura: SO CONDESCENDING.
THEY POURED ON THE PRAISE,
HEAPED ON THE PRAISE, EVEN ON
HER HANDLING OF THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
ACTOR DIRECTOR ROB REINER CALLED
HER A STRONG, BRILLIANT,
EXPERIENCED PUBLIC SERVANT.
JOE BIDEN CLEARLY AGREES.
AT LEAST WHEN NANCY SEEMS TO
HAVE AOC PLUS THREE IN CHECK.
>> I THINK THIS WAS MASTERFUL.
>> Laura: COME ON, MAN.
APPLAUDED EVEN FOR THE SHEER
STRENGTH, AS THIS INFAMOUS PHOTO
IN THE OCTOBER MEETING WITH THE
PRESIDENT AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HER FEMINIST TILES AND MEDIA
BOOSTERS WENT ABSOLUTELY GAGA
OVER IT.
>> CAN WE DO ONE MORE BEAT ON
THE PHOTO?
LOOK AT THE PHOTO OF ONE WOMAN
STANDING UP AND, YOU KNOW,
GIVING IT TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AT THE TABLE
WITH ALL MEN THERE.
SPEAKER PELOSI ON HER FEET
ALONE, ALONE IN THE ROOM.
>> ALL I COULD THINK WELL OF IS
THAT PENCE IS INVOLVED IN THIS
MURKY STUFF TOO AND PELOSI IS
THIRD IN LINE.
>> Laura: MUST'VE BEEN A
PRETTY DIFFERENT COLOR PATTERN
IN THE VIDEO.
BUT NANCY'S THEATRICS DON'T STOP
WITH POINTING.
SHE WALKS AWAY.
SHE COMES BACK TOO.
>> WE DON'T HATE ANYBODY.
>> DON'T MESS WITH ME.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYBODY LEAVE
A MEMBER OF CONGRESS WITH TOUGH
CAPITOL HILL REPORTERS IN
STUNNED SILENCE.
>> Laura: HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
BY GETTING SUCKED INTO
IMPEACHMENT, NANCY PELOSI ALSO
WALKED AWAY FROM COMMON SENSE.
NOW AT TIMES IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS, EVEN THE LAST MONTH, SHE
LOOKED LIKE HER BODY WAS
ACTUALLY REJECTING IMPEACHMENT
LIKE A BAD ORGAN TRANSPLANT.
>> I HAVE NO MESSAGE FOR THEM.
PEOPLE HAVE TO COME TO THEIR OWN
CONCLUSIONS.
THEY HAVE SEEN THE FACTS AS
PRESENTED, THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, THEY KNOW IT, THEY
TAKE THE OATH TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND.
BUT THEY SEE CONSTITUTIONAL
EXPERTS.
THEY THINK ABOUT IT, THEY'LL
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISION.
I DON'T SAY ANYTHING TO THEM.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND, IT'S
INCONTROVERTIBLE EVIDENCE OF AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE, BUT THEY
CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO -- I'M NOT
GOING TO WHIP THESE VOTES.
ODD.
AFTER A YEAR AFTER ACCOMPLISHING
NOTHING OF SUBSTANCE EXCEPT THE
SUPPORT THIS WEEK AFTER OVER A
YEAR FOR THE USMCA, PELOSI'S
FUTURE IS SUDDENLY NOT LOOKING
SO BRIGHT.
THE POLLS SHOW LOIS UP OR FOR
IMPEACHING THIS PRESIDENT, AND
THE SWING STATE OUTLOOK
HORRENDOUS FOR THE DEMOCRATS ON
THAT SAME ISSUE.
THE ECONOMY WAS SOARING, THE
MARKET SOARING 220 POINTS AT THE
CLOSING BELL TODAY.
OF COURSE, THE USMCA IS FINALLY
DONE.
BIG PROGRESS WITH CHINA.
HIS APPROVAL NUMBERS HAVE NOT
BEEN AFFECTED AT ALL FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
HE'S BEEN A BEEN BILLIONS
WHETHER HE'S DOING EVENTS FOR
SCHOOL CHOICE, OR HE'S
FIGHTING ANTI-SEMITISM, OR JUST
RESENTING US, THAT'S ALL, AT
NATO.
MEANWHILE, NANCY'S PARTY UP ON
CAPITOL HILL RIGHT NOW, THE
FLOUNDERING, DESPERATELY TRYING
TO MAKE PEOPLE CARE ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT EVEN THOUGH SHE
DOESN'T CARE ENOUGH TO
WITH THE VOTE FOR IT.
BUT REALITY IS BEGINNING TO SINK
IN.
>> IF YOU LOOKING AT THOSE
INDEPENDENT VOTERS, THE POLLS DO
NOT LOOK GOOD FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
>> WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THIS
HEARING WAS HOW DONALD TRUMP IN
A WAY HAS ALREADY WON.
>> Laura: WOW.
IS THERE A PLAN B HERE?
DOES SAN FRAN GRAND MA'AM HAVE A